[تصفيق]
تصريحات اطلقها الرئيس الفرنسي اثناء
زيارته للصين عن دور بكين الايجابي في حل
الازمه الاوكرانيه فصلت حينها بالمجاملات
السياسيه لكن ان يتبنى ماكرون خطابا حادا
ضد واشنطن والدولار بعد الزياره يحمل
موقفا فرنسيا يتماشى مع دااعه بضروره
استقلاليه اوروبا هو ما لم يكن استكمالا
للمجامله
نهج اوروبي جديد حملته تصريحاته ماكرون
لمجالات
نبره حاده تجاهها واشنطن قد تشهد ازمه
جديده بين الطرفين والتي لن تكون الاولى
خاصه بعد الازمه الدبلوماسيه الناجمه عن
صفقه الغواصات بين باريس وكامبيرا
مكرون عاد من الصين بنبره جديده داعيا
اوروبا الا تنجر وراء ازمات ليست ازماتها
وقد يكون خطرا كبيرا عليها مشيرا الى
التصعيد الحاصل بين الصين والولايات
المتحده اثر ازمه تايوان
سياسه النئي بباريس عن التبعيه للولايات
المتحده وصفت نيويورك تايمز بورقه دوجول
الجنرال والرئيس الفرنسي الاسبق الذي
لطالما اتبع تلك السياسه
ليس من مصلحه اوروبا تسريع ازمه تايوان
وبناء موقفها بالتبعيه لموقف الولايات
المتحده او بتلميحات من الصين
الرئيس الفرنسي اكد على ضروره تعزيز
الصناعات الدفاعيه الاوروبيه وتقليل
الاعتماد على واشنطن خاصه في مجال الامن
هندسه امنيه اوروبيه جديده ظهرت في معرض
حديث ماكرون متوافقه مع ما تدعو اليه
الصين من قبل وتتحد الشراكه والتحالف
الاوروبيه الامريكيه الامني
المتمثله في حلف النيتو
اوروبا يجب ان لا تعتمد على النيتو اوروبا
بحاجه الى اكتساب المزيد من الاستقلاليه
في التقنيه والقدرات الدفاعيه بمنع عن
الولايات المتحده
زياره اثار التساؤلات حول موقف ماكرون
تجاه الصين هل هي نوع من الحمايه لاوروبا
من اثار الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا ام
توجه جديد لمستقبل اوروبي دون تبعيه
للولايات المتحده اذا عمر العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات